what's up good humans in here the
voice-over guy it's a really weird time
right now but we hope you're staying
safe and practicing social distancing
the safety of our cast and crew is of
utmost priority so everything you're
seeing in the next couple of weeks we
already shot a couple weeks ago and
we're also trying to shoot some things
remotely now so stay tuned in the
meanwhile enjoy the episode what
preconceived notions do you have when
you meet someone who got plastic surgery
while some people are very comfortable
to talk about their experience for
others it is still a taboo topic as
they're afraid to be judged by the
society as you watch this episode of odd
man out and pick them all think of what
prior judgments inform your decision we
brought together eight people who got
plastic surgery I got plastic surgery I
got plastic surgery I got plastic
surgery I got plastic surgery I got
plastic surgery I got plastic surgery I
got plastic surgery I got plastic
surgery one of them is a liar if the
group discovers who the liar is they'll
split a cash prize if the liar survives
they win the entire prize who is the odd
men oh I feel like we should see what
we've had done okay rhinoplasty
rhinoplasty
I had buccal fat removal and I also got
lip fillers when they would look at me
it was kinda like okay like they're like
checking me out like up and down to see
like I've had moles removed and I'm here
to remove the moles I've had Top surgery
I had a rhinoplasty rhinoplasty
I had a few I have rhinoplasty leave of
plastic and septoplasty rhinoplasty is a
form of plastic surgery on your nose
very common ones include removing the
dorsal hump and other rhinoplasty czar
to remove nostrils or make the entire
nose smaller
how old was everybody when they got
their stuff done um I suppose two years
ago so I was 18 I was 14 I was 9
housing middle school 22:24 eight months
ago it's pretty like super special but I
felt like she just didn't have like the
look he said that he got cheek surgery
and I had just never heard of the cheek
surgery before all right it's a three
week diet really insecure about how I
looked I used to have chubby cheeks and
I had no lips at all so it was just
stuff that made me feel a lot better and
now I feel like I can actually hold my
head up high so it's stuff that I need
and also my line of work I'm a dancer
and I was kicked in the face so my
septum shifted so half of it was to
shift my septum back so I could breathe
properly the other half was to remove a
bump on my nose it's still very large
nose I'm very well aware of that but it
was because of breathing yeah so I have
had precancerous see screenings since I
was ten years old because my dad died of
melanoma skin cancer so I have had some
precancerous moles and I've had them
removed by a plastic surgery because it
can help reduce gari
[Music]
thank you guys behind good luck I
probably would have talked about my
consultation a little bit more and the
experience I had with my doctor and how
he made me feel really comfortable so a
couple people already did it but I guess
we could go out and say why we got the
surgeries that we did yeah well I was
super insecure about my side profile
I had a dorsal hump so like always like
wanted to know its little slow so I had
rhinoplasty and septoplasty I was mainly
for breathing with Anna I just it wasn't
obvious that she had plastic surgery
she seemed knowledgeable but it just
kind of seemed like she was saying the
same things that everybody else was
saying so yeah I had Top surgery I'm
trans I had very large boobs anyway
that's how I did my surgery I come from
a very Italian family so it was that
very stereotypical like Italian nose it
was a closed procedure so they went
through the inside shaved off the bum
changed the tip a little bit and so now
I have the slope nose and all that yeah
the amount of girls who had rhinoplasty
is there it was one of us Ana and
Miranda gave very very convincing
answers and Jade's were a little more
stereotypical and honestly the look of
her nose she mentioned she had a dorsal
hump removed but there was still a
little bit of a bump there I'd always
been self-conscious of my nose and I
like begging my parents like no no
absolutely not so I told my parents how
about when I'm 18 they're like sure sure
if you still want it when you're 18 we
can help you pay for it and I was like
okay so one I'm 18 I go up and like I'm
ready and they're like oh seriously we
didn't think like you'd actually want
that and I was like no I do so I went
ahead and got it the first one was kind
of like yours it was more correctional
and a lot of people don't know what
labiaplasty is that's surgery on your
vaginal area to tighten the skin I ended
up getting rhinoplasty two years later
and that was kind of more for just
cosmetic reasons I was in pageants and I
just wanted to have a better look and
feel more confident I think especially
in this environment when everyone could
relate to some kind of plastic surgery
was very non-judgmental and I think over
the years I've
been a lot more like comfortable talking
about it for those of you who had to
like pay out of pocket how much did it
end up costing you all insurance covered
some of it but my parents did pay
between eight and ten point was covered
by insurance the breathing part because
my septum was shifted so I yeah i get
filler put in because there's the
revision didn't fix what it was supposed
to fix but the initial procedure it was
9,000 how long did you wait before you
got the revision so i got the first one
the summer before I went into freshman
year in high school and then I got the
revision winter break of my senior year
so yeah yeah I paid out of pocket 4500
for mine I always thought you had to
have a lot of money to have plastic
surgery and I always thought plastic
surgery was cosmetic too I didn't know
that it was also correctional I was so
under my parent's insurance when I did
it and I don't I don't know actually how
much it was I know it was partially
covered because I had the septum and the
Rhino together Anna had said some of it
was covered by insurance and some of it
wasn't I was just like mmm
okay but like how long ago was that when
did you get your surgery when'd you
recover it wasn't quite lining up in my
head no sure it's in cover it was ten
grand literally since like high school
my first job saved up yeah little by
little yeah do you feel like there's a
stigma with plastic surgery oh yeah like
in culture that people think that you're
vain if you've got it yes yeah
especially like cosmetic reasons yeah
[Music]
holy moly y'all a lot of people probably
don't know about cosmetic surgery on
moles I think they saw me Mullen and
they hatin I feel like it's juicing so
who would you say like soup or AG than
most like the using the country my mom
yeah me too my mom like slept in my room
for the whole like first week because I
was just in agony and not sleeping I
always say she's like an angel for doing
yeah I did mine behind my mother's back
I don't want them to know I didn't want
anybody to tell other people in your
life or no was it just not to laughter
because I I didn't have like as much
support going in I didn't want them to
know that I was getting it done I didn't
want them to try to stop me I just
didn't want the negative stigma to
convince me not to do it so something I
did independently on my own my parents
were incredibly supportive they didn't
love that I was getting the surgery at
first especially with like the whole
Jewish identity of making your nose
smaller and getting rid of the bump it's
just like kind of erasing your Jewish
culture which they really weren't
pleased with but once I got the surgery
they're very loving people so they
supported me I get that about the
ethnicity because I'm I'm half Lebanese
and like a lot of people my family have
ethnic noses and one of my cousins asked
me that like well if you have kids and
they have a bump on their nose are you
gonna tell them I think there's like
this balance between embracing who you
are and also recognizing that like if
you change something that's gonna give
you this much more confidence then yeah
do that like there's no judgement there
who supported you my mom for sure she's
the one who like took care of me like
everyone knew but my dad doesn't still
doesn't I mean he will now cuz like in
his eyes I'm his daughter I'm beautiful
like you didn't want me don't ever do
that yeah so I couldn't I was too scared
to tell what you guys say it affected
your life anyway like chain
anything I mean the confidence for sure
yeah yeah 100% for me it was just like
being trans to like again I grew up in
Michigan and that wasn't a thing so like
it was a coupling with like getting the
surgery and also like coming out as
trans but now I'm like I'm look amazing
like let's go do something I think I
used to be a little more judgmental with
like oh like why do you wear like so
much makeup every single day I mean now
we have a lot of makeup like other
people's choices when it comes to
self-confidence I feel a lot more
empathetic towards because the pain it
took so I go through that and like
making that decision for myself it took
a lot and I understand that people are
going to go to like extreme measures to
really build their self-confidence yeah
[Music]
it's a very hard thing to tell mine was
pretty typical rhinoplasty story so
that's like okay well make sense no
second-guessing myself and my gut I felt
like you know could possibly be a mole
and I started questioning Miranda just
because I thought maybe she was supposed
to throw us off she had the perfect or
the typical plastics
oh that sounds bad
[Applause]
just all of their eyes on me I was just
like a science project you know and they
were just I feel like I had my facts
down I was ready to get specific - it's
just they didn't buy mine no one's gonna
dispute me being trans I mean I I knew
that signing up for it I was like this
is like my one to be in like I knew that
I could get to the end even though I'm
such a proponent of like there's no like
look to being someone with plastic
surgery I definitely like learn to
challenge my own beliefs and like
judgments because I was definitely
looking people like okay who looks like
they've had plastic surgery where I
should have really ated that a lot
because it's not always about changing
how the world sees you but it's about
being comfortable in the body that
you're in I think that people think that
people who get plastic surgery are
insecure and vain and I don't think
that's necessarily true I think it's a
very brave thing to go out and change
your body for the purpose of loving
yourself even more what is I am I'm a
virgin I'm a virgin
I am the virgin I'm a virgin one of them
is
[Music]